okay y'all i know i just did morning
coffee thoughts but i had another
morning coffee thought
i look like a mess today whatever
whatever i'm tired
there's some updates in the channel
coming soon and i'm really excited to
tell you guys but i have not i can't
tell you yet but it's gonna be really
cool okay
so so
today's morning coffee thoughts is
advice i would give to a young girl or
even boy
and this is kind of weird advice but
it needs to be said okay
and also my advice you could take it or
leave it right but if i had to start
over and i was like 15 again
i'm only 25 but maybe 14 13. you know
kids are starting [ __ ] earlier and
earlier these days i would say keep as
many doors closed as possible
because this is something i realized
okay
i
how do i put it
i've never okay i've never watched porn
except for one time
in
oh my god can i say that on youtube corn
okay hopefully this video still goes up
anyways except for one time
in
the lobby of my like sophomore year of
college dorm because i told someone that
i hadn't watched it and this man was
just determined to like show me and i
was traumatized scarred have you scarred
anyways
so
and the reason being is like i've always
felt like i don't want to ever be
addicted to that
so
which i know is more common for men but
it happens with women and so like if i
keep that door closed i'll never know
what it's like it's the same and so i
can't miss something i don't know what
it's like it's the same thing with
like even um
drugs right like i've never done i
smoked once or twice in college i never
liked it it was not my thing um
yeah gross
but like for the most part other than
that like i've never really done
drugs like i've never been offered coke
more times than i can count
never did it
um
i'm an offer yeah
and i can't miss this because i've never
i've never done it but alcohol i'll
forever miss
i'll always like there's a part of me
that wants to do it because i used to
drink
and it's not to say you can't do that
stuff in moderation but life is easier
when you don't have doors to bad things
open
like that's why you should be weary of
some people that have cheated in the
past because
they open that door they know what it's
like to cheat i've never cheated
and
it's the same thing
with um
what do you call it
sex
like when you open that door
it's opened
you now miss it you can't miss something
you don't know so
if i if i had to start over i would
literally tell myself like
to keep as many doors closed as possible
and i really did to be honest but
yeah
but
even more so because every time you you
do something like
now you're tempted to do it the same
reason guys i'm so tempted to cheat in
college you may understand
um
i think about it every time something is
due because i don't care about this
degree i don't need it
and
i could just pay someone to do this [ __ ]
for me and i would have more time to
work on youtube
but what keeps me from it is
i'm like do i want to open the door
where i can cheat on things and take
shortcuts
and now that's a thing
no
so i don't but
yeah that's the advice i have keep doors
closed as much as you can
because then most of them
aren't as good as you think so
let me know in the comments morning
coffee thought number two bye